The Joe Rogan Experience so when you
guys like in the early days of the band
what was uh like that's always the
connection with rock and roll and drugs
like this is like that's the narrative
yeah was that in the early days of Pink
Floyd was that the case
it wasn't really no relevant I mean
during the the time when I was smoking
hash every day was 1970 71 70. so it's
pretty
pretty dark side is when we were making
Metals so it's Echoes and but I don't I
don't think it had I don't think it
impinged on my burgeoning writing career
if you like when I was you know starting
to write songs because Sid
um went crazy in nineteen
67.
and so by 69 he wasn't we weren't seeing
him anymore he disappeared completely
and was that because of LSD
no I don't think so but you know that's
the narrative right yeah that's the
narrative or one of the narratives
um
it may be because he he was mixing with
people who were doing acid on a regular
basis I think in 67.
um
and and
um I'm sure he did too much he did too
much of it was he teachering on the edge
of what might be called schizophrenia at
the time I think so probably
a lot of the things that he was saying
and it was right at the beginning of us
getting our first record in any chart
which was Arnold Lane now it was after
online it was in when see Emily play
came out and we were beginning to do TV
shows in England and and I he went very
odd and he started I remember him at top
of the pops in the dressing room one day
um he had hair a bit like that painting
on the wall and uh going sort of like
and then going
looking worried and a bit frightened and
then going
John Lennon doesn't have to do this
you know which was kind of wacky
um
this was like three quarters of the way
through the Beatles career because
they'd only had that one decade really
um and so he he had misgivings about
being on a miming pop show you know and
we said this is what we've worked
towards for the last four or five years
is to be on top of the pups and make a
few quid you know buck up boy let's get
on with it
and uh but he never did back up from
from sort of that moment on really he
wrote a few more songs but nothing of
any any real note and he just got more
and more and more detached until he was
completely wacky and not making any
sense and we may I mean I made a lot of
um attempts to find out what was wrong
and to involve his family you know he
had older brothers so I would ring up
and say hey there's something really
wrong with Roger as they called him
because he wasn't his name was Roger
Barrett not Sid Barrett
I said he's not well I think and one of
the brothers actually came to London and
went and saw him and called me up and
went he's fine you know he's had some
troubling terms but he's actually fine
and that's when Alan he's not he's not
right trust me I've been I live with him
you know anyway
and we tried to get him to a shrink
um so on a number of occasions but he
would never go in and then it just got
weirder and weirder looking what way
weird like what was incommunicative not
making any sense at all
not making any it's like I actually
mentioned one of the one of the periods
one of the moments is in the show
because it's it's in when we play Wish
You Were Here
and I do wish he was here and I I mean
he's partly what that song's about and
Shine On You Crazy Diamond is just
completely about Sid
but we were I told the story in text in
the show and it goes um
we'd been to a meeting at the Capitol
Tower in in Los Angeles and Sid and I
were walking down the street after it
and we stopped at the traffic light at
Hollywood and Vine Hollywood Boulevard
and Vine Street in Los Angeles
and he looked at me and smiled and he
said
it's nice here in Las Vegas isn't it
well we were in L.A
so the he he already had no idea where
he was even like that but then he I I
was saying the thing you'll see at the
show it says then his face darkened
and he looked down at the ground and
spat out one word
and it that sort of encapsulates what it
was like nothing made any sense
disjointed blank disjointed
you know
and there we were all young or very
young and trying to make our way and and
I
by that time David already joined the
band to play guitar because Sitka didn't
play I'm not saying he couldn't well he
couldn't really because both of us
made solo his solo records with him
helped produce his solo records after
that point and he was it was pretty kind
of disjointed and difficult to get him
to do anything did he continue to
deteriorate further after that yeah and
then he went home to live in Cambridge
and he lived a very solitary life now I
I spoke to his sister Rosemary after
that and said could it does it make any
sense you know to go and visit she no
don't do that and she told me I said why
not and she said well
he gets very
um agitated
and upset when if he's reminded of what
happened before whatever this is
he doesn't like it
he doesn't want to see people from his
past he'd rather be left alone and he
did and he used to paint a little bit
and live just on his own in Cambridge
until he died
when he was 60 wow
um
so
I don't know what else to say about it
really it was tragic obviously
and but but
those of us who were in Pink Floyd at
the time experienced it as a
existential
threat as well
[ __ ] me what we gonna do he writes the
bloody songs well I wrote about 20 of
them before but there were nothing Sid
songs were the things that were
different they had that weird English
Romanticism about them you know they
were beautiful I've got a boat you can
write if you like it's got a basket a
bell that rings and things that make it
look good I'd give it to you if I could
but I borrowed it
that's so quirky in terms of its meter
the way the lyric attaches
both to the melody and and to the
um time signature and the tempo of the
thing
is remarkable
um
and it wasn't just you know there were
lots of quirky little songs like that
over all in a very English romantic
tradition and whatever so how could we
possibly survive if the guy writes the
songs and the band goes crazy you're
[ __ ] basically
unless somebody else learns to starts to
write luckily I did I did start to write
I'm not I don't I don't to love because
he was a huge loss
and I did love him